hi I'm Bob San Henry I'm gonna be
talking about Wolfram's new resource
system it's the new technological
framework for distributing wolfram
language content to users through our
cloud
so now that we all are experts on the
data repository we're going to talk
about the more general framework that
houses the data repository and that's
what we're called a resource system so
here's a here's a brief overview of what
we'll we're talking about I'm gonna
start off talking about some of the
terminology
what's a repository what's a resource
what's the publisher account why why do
you need it and then we're gonna spend
the bulk of the talk on the the
repositories that we have now we will
have very shortly and those are the five
that you see there in the middle of the
screen and then I was going to talk
about creating your own resources again
but it doesn't seem like anybody came in
from the last time so I if we have time
maybe we could we'll look at that
because it's a nifty example and then at
the end if we have time we'll look at
some of the repositories that were
planning to add in the medium to long
term and maybe even talk about the
marketplace which is something that
we're hesitant to talk about but is
exciting so the resource system is the
whole technology and it's divided into
repositories so a repository one
repository has content type of a certain
kind so that we already just talked
about the data repository that has data
in it and repositories are distinguished
by the basically by the three features
listed there so each one has a unique
website that has dedicated pages for
each resource each one has a unique
integration into the Wolfram language so
what functions are used to retrieve the
content or work with the content depend
on which repository it's from and then
each repository has specific metadata
within the resources there are some
standard metadata like name they all
have a name but then that's extended for
each repository as needed
so in each repository is made of
resources so resources are sort of
fundamental unit of the resource system
that's why we called it that and you
know the a resource object is basically
a handle for content that contains
metadata so yeah you can like I showed
in the last talk you can you can grab
the metadata and then there's for data
resources the content is retrieved with
resource data for other types of
resources there will be other other
integrations and we'll see that so an
important another important thing about
the resource system is that it's open to
submissions so if you have content that
you think that you would like to publish
and you want us to see if it's good you
can submit it and we'll review it that
requires what we're calling up publisher
account these are new things the the
system for handling publisher accounts
is still sort of in the and in the beta
stage I would say but we can we can do
it we have a form that you can go to the
data repository to ask us for one and
then we'll just communicate over email
that's sort of what I mean by the beta
stage at some point we'll have a nice
little web portal but if you have a
publisher account you can authorize
other users through their wolfram ID or
if you know what your wolfram ID can be
authorized by multiple publisher
accounts so it's not it's not like a
person has a publisher account there's a
publisher count that has authorized
users and users can be authorized by
publisher accounts so if you ask us for
one we'll ask you why you want it what
kind of stuff you want to publish if
that sounds good we'll give you a
publisher account and then again it's a
manual process with humans reviewing
your actual submissions whether their
data or another kind so that's that's
the important thing to realize Oh data
repository it's been out since April we
just talked a lot about it I won't I
won't do anything else with that but
that was the first the first repository
the neural net repository get excited
it's released right now so there's a
whole nother I guess released on Tuesday
when Steven talked to
he sort of sort of stole some of my
talks here so there's another talk about
the neural net repository that Megan and
Matteo are giving tomorrow morning if
you get up and get some coffee in time
they're there they are waving in the
back so so they're gonna they're gonna
give a full half-hour about about the
neural net repository and neural net
resources so let's let's look briefly at
the website so you can see the design
similar data repository but here we have
all of the resources right on the
homepage if we if we pick out one of
these at random it like the data
repository there's a name there's a
brief description there's a more
detailed description there's a brief
summary of how big this thing is but
this one also has this training set
information can you guys see that all
right I'd make it bigger small yeah here
we go this one also has training set
information and for neural networks the
training data is crucial to
understanding the network the same
network trained on different data sets
is going to be a totally different thing
so this tells you what it was trained on
and links to it so you can you can find
it then just like the interpreter we
have this example section where you have
inputs and outputs that you can copy
directly into Wolfram language to use it
has the buttons for opening this up in
cloud or downloading it and then it also
has these construction notebook links
and we'll look at the construction
notebooks in just a second
also neural nets have a higher
dependency on on your Wolfram language
than data does so some of these might
only work in 11:2 or eventually 11:3 and
it'll know what what version you need so
it's nice important and of course
there's a citation of a lot of these
came from published literature on neural
nets we didn't make this all up
ourselves so so this this sites where it
came from so we can look at a quick demo
is that that's imagery style one that
Stephen demoed is the coolest one but he
took that already so I'm gonna use a
different one so here's here's one
relative depth hourglass net trained on
depth in the wild data there's detail
description just like data resources
there can be more than one content
element so the evaluation that is the
main deal that's where the that's the
Train Network that's that's what that's
that's the main event if you say
resource data which in this case is
equivalent to net model so that will
give you the evaluation net and you can
let's let's grab an image from the web
there we go so this if I if I apply this
network to that image what I get back is
some kind of tensor list of vectors
maybe list of matrices I don't know but
I can I can do this and it creates this
cool 3d version of from the 2d image and
it does pretty well and if you want to
know where you know how did I come up
with this I didn't either Megan or
Matteo did and I copied it from the
website because there's examples on the
website right so so that's that's what's
great about having those examples on the
website so so that that's the neural net
repository
you know neural nets are all the rage
these days and they're you know making
they're taking us to the future so so
we're right at the forefront and
distributing those things
the next repository is also being
released right now is the demonstrations
repository so demence the demonstration
project has been around for ten years so
maybe I was a little too excited with
there right now but people have been
submitting demonstrations with cool
manipulates and dynamic content for for
a decade there's over 10,000 of these
eleven thousand four hundred twenty
eight of these but what we're doing is
in the process of migrating them into
the resource system so that they're
easier to use in the Wolfram language so
on that previously you had to go to the
web page download a notebook open that
notebook copy the part that you want put
it into your notebook you might have to
run the initialization code before you
can run it and or you could open a CDF
and run it and CDF player but they're
not as convenient as this probably yes
so yeah yeah the firt the first step is
yeah Margaret the website there are no
media plans to change the website to
match like the the style of the data
repository but I wouldn't rule that out
but it's just it's not the first thing
and the the means of submitting
demonstrations resources has not changed
we're not doing that through resource
submit yet that probably is something
that will will change at some point so
so here's there's a demonstration called
radial engine we can get metadata about
it four-stroke radial engine it we can
give give credit to the author you saw
and what we added some metadata as part
of this which is sort of neat symbols
used so this shows you all the symbols
are used so you can grab a bunch of
these and do some sort of analytics on
on what symbols are are most popular I
think if and lists are going to be on
the list but you can probably remove
trivial ones like that and then resource
data again is the integration tool for
demonstration so so this just gives you
the manipulate right in the language
right and it it it's much easier to to
grab so you know the the highlight of
the demonstrations project being
integrated into the resource system is
that you can do this you can just grab
the manipulate with one line of code
the next repository which is not quite
released but so this is a sneak preview
is the formula repository so this this
is again taking a feature that already
existed
and I am I'm not on a stairway so so so
formula data has been around since
version 10 and there's over a thousand
formulas and formula data but unlike
demonstration where there's a nice
website but the integration to the
language is bad formula data is well
integrated into language but there was
no website and there's an opportunity to
make a good website so here's an example
of using in the language this is really
nothing new
you can grab a resource formula data
works just like it would on the name we
there's you can grab this metadata so
that that's new you can you can get
metadata for these things but the fun
part is that each of these formula will
have a web page similar you know says
some of the part of this similar the
name description and detail description
here there's also going to be a pretty
little formula and a table describing it
but here the fun part is that they're
all going to have these live forms where
you can you can put in you know whatever
values you want it you can put in units
or it can infer units and it'll give you
a response you can see obviously we have
some formatting work to do this sort of
ugly but that this each formula will
have a live web page that's publicly
accessible and you can use to to
calculate solutions for those formulas
and once again of course they're
examples and citation information so
that's the formula repository which
hopefully will be out in in a matter of
weeks not months after that is the
function repository which is not just a
repackaging of existing things it's
something brand new and it's something
that will allow what people have wanted
for a long time in in sort of a simple
form and that's to have standard
resources that you can use to extend
your local copy of Wolfram language
so you can you can import function
definitions and use them in your session
and you get to choose which which ones
you import and which ones you don't so
so here's a quick example where we have
something called lookup sequence
yeah it has metadata again that we can
look if I use this function resource
function what it gives me back is this
blob which is what we call a resource
function object so this is like a
generalization of lookup if you're used
to lookup so lookup source doesn't take
this list of keys to look deeper and
deeper into something but this one does
so it's looking for people and then the
person named Suzanne and then Suzanne's
hobbies and if at any point it doesn't
find that it'll give a default which is
really nice to use so that in the nested
thing it doesn't throw errors that
aren't handled well so of course this
exact function isn't important what's
important is that we have this tool for
adding these resource functions into
your session and you can you can
register these which is another notion
that so that it persists from session to
session we'll just do one more example
because this one's sort of more fun
symbol dependency graph so this this
takes a symbol and creates a graph
object for the dependencies so once
again I can get the function so here I
just have ABC a depends on B and C B
depends on C C doesn't depend on either
of them I can make this simple graph to
a more interesting one what I'm doing
here is I'm grabbing the actual symbol
that underlies this resource function so
we have this resource function symbol
graph and if I if I take the resource
object and look at symbol name there's
this there's this symbol underneath so
I'm taking that and using it to create a
graph of its own dependencies so it's
eating itself a little bit and and you
can see in each each this tooltip means
that you
one of these is some some symbol in that
context it's probably really small to
see that's I don't know if that's any
better all right so so yeah this this is
neat because it will allow let me go
just go back it'll allow it sort of a
new class of function so what functions
make sense for the function repository
as opposed to just creating new symbols
in standard Wolfram language and there
are a few times where that makes sense
one is when it's sort of something
that's very niche that doesn't that most
people won't want another one is when
it's something neat but hasn't really
been fully developed it's a little
underdeveloped we can sort of use the
function repository as a trial ground
and at some point it might be promoted
to a system level function there are a
couple other cases where we in the past
we've had tools that we thought were
cool but just not right and we could
maybe put those right in right in the
function repository so here's here's a
nifty little example where I'm putting a
bunch of these different resource types
together
so we've resource data that's grabbing
information about our solar system from
from the data repository I'm using that
same lookup sequence that we saw on the
last slide to dig more than one level
deep into the data and then I'm using
the formula resource for gravitational
acceleration and I'm applying the values
for Europa to that formula and so so
that that all comes together and gives
us a result let's make sure to ask alpha
and make sure it's right hey it worked
so so yeah all the this is to
demonstrate that you know the Wolfram
language is a coherent system where
things naturally work together
these aren't packages developed by
people who've never met each other that
you need converters to go between all
these repositories are you know
wolfram language things that are all
that all work so I think you were all
we're here for de repository talk where
we saw how to create your own resource
so here's here I've creating a function
resource I have time so we'll do this
one so here here what I'm doing is find
faces classify with notable person there
is one of our built in machine learning
things I'm sticking his name and a
rectangle on the face and I'm making it
so that if I click on the name see how
the network there we go we can get a we
can get Wikipedia data back from it so
here's a nice there's a nice little
function we're not going to put this in
system level context anytime soon but
but maybe maybe I want to deploy it to
my own cloud or maybe I want to submit
it and see if it's good enough for the
repository we can we can see who I look
like oh no okay we'll just scroll down
alright so so so that's a function and
if i want to create a resource object
out of it it's as simple as just saying
that it's a function resource giving it
a name giving a description and then it
works just like just like one from the
repository so here's that nice function
blob if I want to create if I want to
deploy it or submit it it's nice to add
additional metadata and examples so
those template notebooks are great for
this and we will have template notebooks
for each repository but right now the
data ones the only one that's released
so if you're ambitious and you want to
get something done before then you can
do it just like this put all the
metadata and Association if you ask for
an example notebook but known exists it
you know so creates one for you that you
can modify so I'll just create create a
function and let's see I'll grab this
guy
it's a resource function that guy and
then I'll say I identify a celeb and
I'll grab that and okay who's got who's
got a favorite celebrity anybody anybody
what Clooney good one that's let's see
how that does hey work alright so so now
we have an example notebook and we can
cloud deploy this publicly and there's a
there's there's my nice HTML summary and
again you can grab that cloud object and
send it to your colleagues and they can
use your function to find out they look
like serial killers from the language
instead of from the notebook you can do
resource submit as well so if I submit
this I should get back a submission
object and that enters it into the queue
where it will be reviewed by humans so
so that that's sort of the current state
for the future we want to have an API
repository where instead of the content
being downloaded and running on your
machine you we are going to host api's
in our cloud that you can run Wolfram
language content some of it might just
be a web deployed form of a standard
Wolfram language symbol some of it might
be new cool things that are specifically
useful to be an API that maybe a webpage
would want to ping we want Pacolet
resources which is sort of like the the
Big Brother to the function resource so
a function resource just takes a single
function and and sort of stores in
memory a Pacolet resource would be a
prop
Pacolet with you know with source files
and notebooks and front-end stuff and
all sorts of whatever whatever you we'd
have in our standard packets which some
of you might be very familiar with other
things like device connection and
service connections will be coming down
the pipeline as well and then the last
thing I guess I'll just hint at is
adding a Marketplace on top of the whole
resource system where so right now
everything is public and free most of
the stuff that we put up there will
probably continue to be that way but in
order to entice you all the ones with
with red badges not black badges too to
make stuff well we're going to create a
way for you to to charge people to use
it and and we'll take a small piece and
you'll get a big piece and everyone will
be happy the details of that are still
very much being worked out so don't ask
me exactly how much it'll cost
yeah so that that's it and they time for
questions and if you want to ask about
data repository now if you thought it
was something new
feel free yes
so when you say package you mean like da
dam or wal file right I imagine so I
imagine the Pacolet resource the packet
repository being the the method to
distribute content like that so you know
packets are basically wrappers on a lot
of times package files that are that are
stored in a way that they're easy to
load and the system knows how to
integrate them
that's all pack loose so we'll probably
want to create something that wraps it
up automatically for you and turns a
package into Pacolet but when that comes
out that's probably on the scale of
months it'll be the means of
distributing those sort of things more
questions no that's it
[Applause]